hey everybody what's going on we just
got out of seeing dune here in singapore
it was a media screening i even got the
bracelet on right here and i want to
give you my first impressions of the
movie here i know a lot of you in
america are not going to be able to see
this till october in singapore we are
very fortunate to be one of the few
countries outside the venice film
festival to be able to see it early uh
so big thank you to warner brothers
singapore for that but
i gotta talk about this movie because
this movie surprised me i like denis
villeneuve honestly i like his directing
uh bladerunner 2049 was pretty good but
slow at times prisoners was great you
know and i thought this movie was going
to be a very draggy movie when they told
me the cast i mean it is star studded
from the top to the bottom but when they
mentioned timothy chamelet i was a
little bit like oh really i mean is it
going to work with him
so i went in with sort of mediocre
expectations i'm gonna be honest with
you guys this movie
blew me away it was way above what i
thought it was going to be it's just as
beautiful as the trailers the first
scene comes on you are like okay we are
in a completely different world and one
thing i appreciate about it is is the
trailers give you enough to want to get
you into the movie theaters but once you
sit in
you are just brought into this world
building magnificent cinema masterpiece
from denver new that i think
is gonna get some academy awards now i
don't know if it'll get best film or
best picture but i definitely think
you're gonna get best cinematographer
out of this
art direction uh special effects i mean
score there are so many good things
about this movie so let's talk about the
story for a minute because a lot of
people say based off the book this is an
impossible book to make a movie from
right we saw the 1980s version of dune
it was okay some people loved it some
people just didn't like it at all
this one i have to say i didn't read the
book i don't like reading books before
going to the movie theater because it
will never be the same just won't be but
the world building that they did with
this and the way that they told the
story was very easy to understand you're
really going to get this in the first 15
to 20 minutes of who are the good guys
who are the bad guys what this story is
about on its premise
and then it kind of takes you on that
journey from there
and i mean all the performances are good
i was worried specifically about timothy
chamele's character because you know
when i
saw you know the trailers and i saw paul
there for the first time i'm like going
this guy looks
is he going to just whine and pout the
entire movie is this going to be the
sulkin look you know what i mean but
it's not that paul's journey was
actually one of the more exciting ones
for me and i think denis valeneu did a
fantastic job with that he's not a mary
sue he's not some guy that's able to do
everything and anything right away
um you in some of these movies fall into
that trap based on you know they're
trying to cut time to get to the point
of the film or whatever the case may be
you really get invested in his journey
along the way and it's a uh
you it's i don't want to give away too
much but
it really sets up for a good part two
and i can't wait to see that rebecca
ferguson as his mother
she's a phenomenal actress and this
character has so much more there's so
much underneath you cannot wait to see
what comes out in part two of this film
but it gives you enough to really be
invested with her and she just knocks it
out of the park um oscar isaac as his
father does a fantastic job you see that
bond between father and son you really
believe it and
he's just i love the nuances with him as
well uh jason momoa now usually we're
like yeah i'm jason mamoa man yeah give
me a guinness and he's aquaman
he's toned it down guys he does fit into
this film i was worried about that but
actually he fits into this film really
well as duncan and he's sort of paul's
mentor in this film in terms of you know
combat a little bit in terms of training
in terms of you know uh piloting things
like that he learns a lot of these
things from his mentors and also josh
brolin's character gurney in this so you
get that sense that he's really being
built up to be this leader of course
but
there are some really interesting facets
along the way that make you
think can he be this or some of those
pressures that he feels as a character
i'm talking about paul right now
becoming this person so i love how they
really set up that story in that regard
dave bautista is also really good in
this he doesn't say a lot
but he's very impactful he is a tour de
force on screen with this zendaya was
interesting in this film because we see
her a lot in the trailers
and that's pretty much what you see of
her in the film she's not in it quite a
bit i mean people already said this
already
but she is an integral part of this
movie all the way through and you do
feel the presence all the way in it but
the story is really about paul and his
journey uh in iraqus now in terms of
pacing in this film i was worried it was
going to be kind of long-winded right
because when i saw blade runner 2049
it's a nice looking film but it felt
very long-winded
and it felt draggy at times now there
are some moments in this film that are
slower than others and you know if i was
to look at it from a maybe a critic's
perspective i might say maybe cut off 15
20 minutes out of this film might you
know tighten things up a bit but
one of the things that you get out of
those slower moments are character
building in the moments with some of the
supporting characters or even paul
himself so it was one of those things
where i had to go to the bathroom in the
movie but i didn't know when to go into
the bathroom because every time i want
to go to the bathroom something else
came up and i'm like okay i got to stay
here for this so
if that's the case then the movie's
pacing is pretty good in my personal
opinion based on when i could go to the
bathroom that makes any sense anyway um
i definitely recommend this film and for
you guys in america i know it is opening
up the same day in the theaters as on
hbo max
unless you have a top-tier home theater
system
beautiful screen or projector
fantastic speakers sound proof room
this is
cinematic art and it needs to be seen in
the theaters all right those are my
thoughts on it anyway let me know your
thoughts in the comment section below is
this a film you're excited to see any
questions you have for me i'll try to
answer them without spoiling it for you
with that stay safe take care and i'll
chat in the next one
[Music]
you